each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
back from lunch that's a pleasure it was
great lunch everybody enjoyed it yeah
and welcome to the security and software
development session we'd like to kick it
off with doctors Barbara Endicott papas
keys excuse me Barbara i butchered that
from University of Washington yeah and
Kirsten Ferguson Boucher from a burst
with ya very good University in Wales
and they are going to give us a great
presentation called risk assessment and
cloud strategy development going to go
over a little bit of background on
security that's probably not news to the
people in this room as a level set to
describing what we're doing at the
University of Washington with the center
of information assurance and
cybersecurity and then segwaying into
our collaboration with Wales and we're
taking a slightly different view with
this presentation we're looking at some
business issues I like to start with my
favorite quotes from the chief
information security officer at the
University of Washington he's very fond
of saying that if the internet were a
street I wouldn't walk it in day time I
think what's most astounding is the idea
that organized crime makes more money on
the internet than they do from drugs now
I'm not sure where the FBI gets that
information I don't believe that
organized crime publishes annual reports
but albeit it is a comment that they
have made in presentations I have heard
so the bottom line is from a security
perspective it's not pretty out there
we're all aware that the spectrum of
threats has changed in the last 10 years
as a practitioner I started in the
security space when we were most worried
about recreational hackers the 12 year
olds that would stay up all night and
cause mischief we've now graduated to
the professional hackers of course the
organized criminals and nation states
that have a very determined
motive money national interests and it
becomes compelling and of course you're
all familiar with this particular chart
the famous X chart that basically states
looking from left to right that over
time it has taken less and less effort
to execute increasingly complex attacks
basically because hackers are nothing if
they're not willing to share and share
their tools making it easy for people to
get aboard and do dangerous things so
what have we learned from our
experiences with the internet and i
would say number one from my perspective
is design in cyber security from the
get-go and we look at the history of the
internet that was not a requirement from
the beginning we're talking about
enabling sharing amongst known parties
very quickly as the internet became
commercialized we began to experience
these unintended consequences but cyber
security from the beginning was not a
requirement and so what can we take to
the cloud perhaps the same concept that
we need to think about security from the
beginning now the center that I operate
at the University takes a
multidisciplinary approach we have been
involved with the legal folks with the
business folks Computer Science
Information science so we basically
basically look at a cross-disciplinary
view of this problem space and we look
at this space from the user perspective
from an implementation perspective last
year that implementation perspective
embraced the cloud for many reasons the
cloud uptake was a lot greater and
faster than originally was predicted by
sources like Gartner the cloud is
basically forming over Washington State
so we have a front-row seat on the
development of the cloud this is fairly
exciting for those of us who live here
we're witnessing a paradigm shift and at
the information school where I mostly
reside we are preparing people to manage
information systems
we're aware that sources like Gartner
are claiming that eighty-five percent of
these jobs are going to go away as we
know them and that the big emphasis for
implementers is going to be data and
information management issues and so
this has a great deal of relevance in at
the University and for the position that
I hold now let's look at what the pond
iment Institute is saying about cloud
providers and how they view the security
space this report came out April 11
April in 2011 excuse me and it had some
very interesting things to say now I'm
not saying this study isn't without its
flaws here's a summary of flight of
findings they're basically claiming that
cloud providers overwhelmingly believe
that the security problem is the users
problem and when we look at the sample
size that was queried we see that while
a large number of organizations in
Europe and the UK and the American
continent were queried there was a small
respondent size to that particular
survey and when we look at how cloud
providers perceive themselves in their
confidence in supplying security note
that they are fairly confident that they
are meeting user needs for security in
the cloud but when you look at what the
cloud providers perceive as the owner of
the security space there by a majority
saying that it's the cloud user that
takes primary responsibility I see a
conflict there yes we're doing a great
job with security basically this is the
users responsibility so we have one of
these things and so when we look at the
countries involved in the sample size in
the European Space the study largely
drew on UK participants and when the
question was asked who is most concerned
about cloud security is at the US or
Europe we see that perhaps Europeans are
slow
more concerned and this is consistent
with experiences that we've had with
other IT innovations where the Europeans
watch the Americans and maybe take a
more studied approach to adoption and
then take the lessons learned from the
Americans who embrace technology with
abandon and that's a good thing so what
I'd like to introduce is a study that
was done by our UK colleagues from
Everest with where they did a similar
study but at a more detailed level
looking at storing information in the
cloud from their perspective now what's
interesting about this particular study
is that an extension of this research
could indeed assist in accelerating
uptake in the European countries because
we certainly are identifying where
potential users are seeing showstoppers
so we are planning to continue this
research this initial study was chaired
by my colleague Kirsten Ferguson Boucher
yes so we um we started this research
project last year and the main aim was
to investigate the management
operational technical issues but from a
record-keeping perspective I'm based in
the Department of Information studies at
aberystwyth so we're looking at some of
the longer-term requirements for keeping
and the data that's being stored in the
cloud so that was one of our objectives
at the beginning and but we also wanted
to develop two toolkit to assist
information professionals and broader
informational professionals not just the
technological side because these are
people around the table and these
decisions are made as Barbara alluded to
the uptake has been less in Europe and
I'm not sure if that isn't a personality
thing we're a lot more circumspect
perhaps in what we do in Europe but also
we obviously we have a lot more
stringent regulations which control and
affect our decision making processes so
this was the actual research methodology
we
first of all we took quite a detailed
literature review looking specifically
at information governance and assurance
though there isn't much which is good
thing to know I mean at the end of the
day it's not been something it's
actually coming in on to the radar until
a last sort of six months or so it's
evidence that was so early adoption
stage in Europe and we also undertook a
series of consultations we did do an
online questionnaire similar to that
project before quite low response rates
we were surprised and at the same time
there was some being done in educational
institutions as well they've got a
slightly higher rate but generally
speaking people are not responding
quickly to say what they're doing I
think is a lot of it's not happening yet
but also because they haven't actually
gone through the thought processes so
from our perspective a good time to get
involved we also did three in-depth kind
of case studies with the Guardian Media
Group melrose resources which is quite a
small organization who look at it's kind
of like security side but also longer
term preservation issues and also the
cat the UK government the cabinet office
at the moment they're in the process of
creating a private cloud and called
g-cloud so this is something that's
actually happening in the UK government
at the moment so again people that you
would hope were thinking about some of
the governance and assurance issues and
we also had an event last year in
Manchester an unconference where we
pretty well left it to the floor to
discuss some of the issues so this is
where we got quite a lot of our data
from so survey results were not
unsurprising thirty percent have used
cloud computing in some way 17 or
thinking about it 41 interested but no
active plans and so it's really that
forty-one percent that I would say are
the interesting group why they not
actually engaging yet actually the
Ponemon Institute study it has that I
can get you a copy yeah yeah yeah that's
an interesting question I can send you
that we'd yeah because I did look at it
and I can't member the actual figures
but it is significantly low
to repeat the question yes ed was asking
what the comparable data looked like for
the u.s. in terms of adoption rates we
did have that overall number that that
seemed to indicate that it was different
here in the US but yeah the other kids
learn and these are some of the main
concerns but what's interesting here is
they're not the main concerns of the I
to fraternity these are the main
concerns of organizations particularly
from that information and record-keeping
perspective so the first thing that
actually comes up on that list is
destruction of data perhaps surprisingly
and lots of control perhaps not so
surprising the data protection again
privacy issues are always going to be
something which and is significant
elements in you know concerning
organizations but I think that first one
the destruction of data is quite an
interesting one and one that doesn't
look will come to later in there in the
discussion so again what are they what
the governance issues mentioned the
privacy in the data protection one and
obviously each country has different
legislation the EU at the moment is in
the process of changing our legislation
and and at the moment however the the
cloud has there are significant issues
we're getting information and private
data into the cloud sensitive data into
the cloud from a European perspective
why do compliance issues the new
discovery and again European legislation
is a lot more complex in a lot of ways
we're more circumspect in what we do so
these perhaps impact quite heavily got
things like confidentiality and the
ability to audit service which again
I'll come back to as well lots of
control over data so really what we were
saying at from the data that we've
collected as people are quite willing to
get engaged in the cloud but it's a risk
assessment exercise and it's building
these trust relationships so again play
at your own risk and it's moes what
we're interested in is how do you
actually then make these risk
assessments we had a top ten set and
that came out of our research which the
top ten questions I've got two slides on
that which I'll not go through but
there's a summary here they basically
cluster into
questions that relate to performance
specifically efficient thing costs which
you would expect and monitoring and
total costs obviously organizations are
going to be concerned with that but
there are quite a lot that relate to
alignment of organizational objectives
and how do you actually up
responsibilities in the impact to the
house outsourcing those associated with
coming back to Barbara's talk before the
information assurance and value element
how are we actually using the
information in the cloud to bring value
to the organization and and finally that
risk which again will come back to so
it's clear that a lot of the findings
why people aren't getting involved in
the cloud relate specifically to
information governance and assurance ie
the handling of data in the cloud and
decisions can only be taken in a wider
context within organizations so what we
are in terms of our research looking at
now is what is this complex structure of
assessments it isn't just specifically
the implementation of that IT in terms
of being a solution for that particular
IT problem it's all about value
alignment performance and assurance of
all information within this wider
framework so I've come up with this
vapor I just put there how to pronounce
it looks a bit old and but it's really
about the value of information alignment
with business objectives assurance and
proving that you're actually meeting
those kind of assurance requirements in
a performance and risk framework so it's
a holistic approach to information
governance and assurance and part of
this model also attempts to take
advantage of the changes in user
practice and we've seen a lot of changes
as a result of social media and
depending on the nature of organizations
a lot harder to actually instruct people
in terms of what they should be doing to
meet a lot of these objectives because
users are used to operating differently
in their own home environment they don't
expect to come into the workplace now
and be given a lot of regulations and
governance and in terms of how they
operate we've also tried to kind of work
in conjunction with existing processes
and procedures in the organizations
because again making those kind of
changes is quite difficult but we are
trying to add value within this
performance and risk framework so what
we did with in the toolkit is we divided
it into three sections we've looked at
preparing to go into the cloud managing
and then ultimately operating in the
cloud this is actually a summary
of Microsoft's toolkit which looked at
data governance privacy confidentially
and compliance so actually Microsoft or
a bit ahead of the game and that they
are starting to think about these sorts
of issues you can see the kind of ways
they've approached it which is kind of
interesting comparison and there are
other governance papers and literature
that is starting to appear about cloud
specifically but what we've done is try
and actually give people something the
hands on that they can do through it
each of the stages so you're looking at
preparing things like information
classification I'm talking here not just
in terms of security classification I
mean actually providing classifications
that enable you to find information
afterwards risk assessments then
actually when managing in the cloud and
I'm going to look in a bit more detail
in a minute at the information
management one compliance contract cost
monitoring and then operating in the
cloud so forwards as a I'll leave these
slides there there there for reference
afterwards but basically that's about
your legal framework and this is where
Europe perhaps has more issues and
existing internal systems the IP IT
infrastructure and you serve central
business drivers and I've highlighted
classification there because how your
information goes into the cloud and in
terms of storage is how it's going to
come out so there are some significant
issues for organizations but doesn't
happen there sorry just going to go back
because i overshot by about 16 slides i
think roughly i'll come back to that bit
so that there are two slides on
operating and i'm going to go to this
one so i thought as an example this is
the kind of thing that's in the toolkit
so if you take that heading it talks
about information management and the
structure of our particular tool kit
starts with a consideration each the
topic so in this particular instance
you're looking at information stored in
the cloud how's it going to be managed
in terms of the organization's existing
management systems so you're looking at
authenticity reliability and integrity
of information over time and also
ensuring that it's accessible put in the
overtime thing here because I seems to
be a lot of talk about what's happening
now of course which is very relevant but
from information management and
record-keeping you're looking at longer
and issues it's not just how the data is
being accessed and
now it's how it's going to be accessed
and used for the foreseeable future you
think about pension records for example
people always think of this as being
kind of archival or some sort of issue
for far into the future but really each
organization has things like pension
records you need to know exactly how
they're being managed over the entire
lifecycle of that information so the
rationale so the organization needs to
ensure that policies and procedures
surrounding that are there for the whole
life cycle of the organization we're
talking about classification appraisal
and disposal of information that one
that came up is number one I'm in terms
of what information management
professionals are worried about so the
kinds of questions that we've actually
gotten a toolkit are what impact will
the management of information stored in
the cloud have can we get from sort of
assurance and a lot of issues that
relate to the contracts at the moment
which is they're very much a kind of
one-size-fits-all contract and doesn't
necessarily apply to each organization
these are the sorts of questions that
organizations need to be able to answer
and can we actually show that things
have been encrypted or protected or so
it's more of an evidence base and these
are gonna questions that are relate
specifically to making and fixing
information in the cloud and what's been
created with the implications for it if
there's metadata to be attached can we
is a different metadata that we need in
the cloud and for keeping and seeking as
I e you're searching for information but
keeping it for the longer term I'm
talking full classification here have we
actually got enough information there
that you can get everything that relates
to these sorts of processes out and
things like retention and disposal
schedules how is it going to be
destroyed and the preservation needs
which are touched on before these longer
term retention can it beat it doesn't
need to be transferred to a digital
archive if you've gots a governmental
information that should be going into an
archival storage or is there a place of
legal deposit is it just going to have a
shorter term requirement or should it
remain in the cloud are the ways of
actually preserving the information in
the cloud so it comes back to this kind
of risk context and I've tried to going
to neutralize a lot of term takes a lot
of things come with understandings from
different disciplines but your legal
risks are really about ensuring that
you've got the right stuff
including the context in which it was
created contents one thing but if you
don't know when things are created that
whole metadata and structure side of
things you need to think about that in
terms of legal requirements the
structural risk if young got your
systems in architecture for that
particular information needs to be
managed through the life cycle systems
risks and find the business mystic we
don't monitor these activities this is
perhaps why we're coming back to the
contracts we need to be able to see how
they are actually being monitored and
have evidence not only that we've
checked it but that we know it's been
done so it's that kind of risk framework
we talked about accordance there or I've
talked about business legal system and
structural quadrants so just drilling
down there you can have controls that
work within the organization they relate
mainly to sort of access issues both
enabling access but also withholding
access of appropriate and it links that
concept of authenticity legal quadrant
again you're looking at checks miss
about appraisal it's about appraising
the information that we hold there are
cost implications for putting everything
into the cloud organizational ones and
also accessing information afterwards
there's like data protection you're not
supposed to hold information for longer
than it's actually going to be required
or was stated to be required so you need
to be able to destroy and know that it's
been destroyed and it's maintained
confidentiality over that period go back
to the context can you get at it is it
classified can you ensure that during
that period it's been reliably looked
after and that there is a kind of
integrity framework to it and then
finally the containers how are you going
to prefer to preserve it for the longer
time and will it be available so some of
the solutions are that come from my neck
of the woods as in the information
management side under you checked you've
got things like a pro so we're talking
with tension of disposal schedules and
quite simplistic tools in one way that
basically applies your entire legal
framework to the data that you hold you
have an overview of the organization
data that's held and you know what you
need to keep for how long and that needs
to be addressed specifically terms of
context it is things like classification
your record plans youth force or I how
do you access that information the
controls from the access and security
side well Barbara has touched on that
but there are specifics not to just the
security side it's also got no
management element which is the
presentation that we were at the it was
the I school and the icon yeah that's
right we had a somebody from microsoft
it came to that we talked about the
encryption side you can encrypt but you
need also to be able to access the data
afterward they were looking at ways and
means of actually being axle to search
the data afterwards so proper encryption
is great you can't get asset but then
you can't actually get at it and so you
need to be able to and so it's that sort
of enabling as well as securing and
perspective and then I think I mentioned
before the containers how are we going
to do that so really what Barbara and I
have come to now is what we want to do
the tool kits available that tool kits
available and I've at the end of the
slide and you can I've given the
websites etc for accessing that so if
you're an organization there are a
series of questions that you can ask to
get you started but it is very much
preliminary research what we want to
look at now and takes it one stage
further and it's issues relating to this
kind of trust and understanding element
cloud is very much a buzzword most
organizations want to think about it
because it well it sounds quite sexy and
it might be interesting they're not at a
point where they're thinking about what
exactly does that mean and how can I
systematically look at what I'm going to
do with my data and so certainly in
Europe as i said i'm not sure if that is
related to our slightly more circumspect
but the engagement hasn't been a
significant so perhaps these sorts of
governance and assurance frameworks
might encourage more uptake so what we
wanna do is broaden that particular tool
kit to include these wider information
governance dimensions and which are
concerned to organizations and but it's
not just really about the cloud when
obviously the cloud is the new business
model for the here and now but these
sorts of governance issues don't really
alter depending on the technology so if
you get this kind of information
assurance structure right it should be
applicable regardless of the technology
that's actually being used so we're
thinking about that kind of genera
sizing for all information regardless of
format which would hopefully take us
forward so that's our contact
information if people obviously want to
get in touch and we do have section for
questions i'm actually just nipping on
to say that
the cloud the resources are available at
that and that website we did quite an
extensive literature review and there is
an opportunity to come to contribute if
you wanted to add more things to our um
our delicious tags although ironically
not quite sure what's happening with
delicious are one out no but that's
where we were putting everything and the
unconference is available and the
toolkits actually available at their
website as well so just wanted to point
that up and we'll go back to questions
okay we have plenty of time for
questions so i can i pick up speed yes
so i'm interested in the extent to which
you think uptake in europe is impeded by
the fact that the cloud today is largely
hosted in the united states or by US
companies and i've heard that there are
a set of legal framework issues for
example what's the status of data in
motion as it gets forwarded along the
fact that say European data stored in
the United States might be subject to us
disclosure laws even if its data or
maybe even data in a server owned by a
US company located elsewhere blah blah
you know I think the patterns changing a
bit because a lot of the vendors are
starting to say where the data is
actually held but because the benefit of
the cloud is that you can it's scalable
and you put data wherever but from a
European perspective we have to know has
to be within the 27 countries of the
European Union and if it's not held
within those boundaries then things like
data protection legislation you're in
breach so yeah we have really quite
specific having said all of that does
european initiatives going through at
the moment that are looking at how we
can address that because realistically
and it's quite limiting in terms of the
data but yes and obviously your then
once you move into the other
jurisdictions you're actually having to
negotiate / jurisdiction which is you
know really it's a quite limiting to say
the least so yes you're losing a lot of
benefits the cloud on that basis yeah
other questions one here here you go
so in your survey is a wonder if you
noticed or did you have any indication
of different attitude between small
medium enterprises and large
organizations interestingly that's my
next to my personal next set of research
which is to look at some of the impact
factors because I think size of
organization is quite significant I
think type of organization but these are
very much feelings that I got hunches
from having done this research we didn't
specifically look at those questions so
I'd like to that's my next set of
research is to look at the specific
impact factors I think size of
organization I think type of data I
suspect they're the kinds of information
projects that are being undertaken we've
seen loads of applications here over the
last two days and but i think the kinds
of actual implementations and users that
have been put to i think that will be
quite significant in terms of impact
factors so i have a series now i'm also
looking at different geographical
locations back to that question I look
at Europe us and I want to look at say
India as an example of how this sort of
asian it may vary in the different
continents and things so I think there
are quite a lot of impact factors and I
don't think you can you can genera size
to a certain degree in terms of asking
the right questions but I think it's
very much down to context and that I
think to me and I said it applies the
cloud but it'll apply to any other new
technology or new kind of technological
business model and as time moves on so
yes definitely there's an impact but I
can't prove it yet I will do okay we
have time for one quick question if
there's one out there okay I see none so
please join me in thanking dr. Endicott
philosophy and keep Ferguson boucher
thank you okay we'll just take a very
brief time here too is that working
okay the be just a couple seconds here
we gotta get load the other presentation
on to the my name is khan Iran I'm from
University College Dublin center for
cyber crime investigation I'm not a
doctor yet I'm a PhD candidate and I
hope to finish my PhD by the end of this
year so today I'm going to give the
audience a brief introduction on the
research I've been doing throughout my
PhD I started to look at the problem of
cloud forensics and the digital
investigation in the cloud two years ago
since I began to begin to do my PhD work
basically it concerns how to carry out
digital education in cloud computing
environments and after two years I think
I figure out that this is going to take
me maybe more ten ten years more to work
on this area because it's so big and
agreeing and nothing really has been
done yet in this area so basically my
PhD will be like my dissertation will be
like a lot of questions and ideas on how
to solve this problem so these are some
of the coercers of the paper i will be
mentioning in this talk mark crosby is a
security architect from IBM ireland and
joshua james is my colleague and in the
research center ibrahim burgundy is a
professor at a university from UAE and
professor Jocassee is the head of
computer science and informatics in UCD
and he's also the director of the
research center the haka charity is my
joke Ozzy is my supervisor and how
kacheri is my co supervisor from UCD and
I'm funded by oxide and eid s this
company which is building Airbus's
sounds very cool digital my sketch in
the cloud so what is digital
investigation a cloud basically I think
in the future cyberspace will be powered
by the cloud so digit investigation
cloud is more or less the future of
digital education in the cyberspace and
it's a very wide area because it's not
only about prosecuting the
cybercriminals it's also about how to
find out what's going on in the cloud
which is the concern of many people who
are now thinking about adopting cloud
computing or already using cloud
computing how to figure out what's going
on what happened in cloud so cloud
computing providers with global
interconnection openness and
interoperability and at the same time it
provides the criminals more easier
access to to the cyberspace and more
safe havens and in the future consumer
business political scientific and
educational activities will be powered
by cloud computing and the cyber crime
is estimated to have 1 105 billion
dollar value per year it's bigger than
drug dealing as mentioned by the
previous speaker but at the same time
law enforcement is not catching up as
usual and as we expected because it's
very hard to play catch-up with the bad
guys I was reading article two days ago
on why the bad guys is hard to catch
because they just need to try to break
the vase and they just need to catch one
chance and they can do that but for the
good guys to catch them they have to be
they had to they have to succeed one
hundred percent of the time which is
very challenging and digital evidence is
still that the miscibility of digital
evidence in the cord is still very
complicated issue especially comes to
cloud computing so this is very recent
document from the White House from Obama
international strategy for cyberspace
issued last month and it's mentioned in
this document that states must identify
and prosecute cyber criminals to ensure
laws and practices deny criminals safe
havens and cooperate with international
criminal investigations in a timely
manner this seems to be a goal for for
us as a country and a long-term strategy
for the cyberspace
but it's very complicated issue
concerning lots of technical challenges
organizational challenges and
international collaboration and and
basically now we still cannot even
answer this question what happened and
what is happening in the cloud which is
very basic fundamental to achieve this
goal so there's a long way to go as I
was carry on my research at beginning I
i made a simulated cloud myself and it's
a very small project I was trying to
simulate the simulated some crimes and
similar similar some crimes and try to
figure out how to go through the
investigation process in the simulated
cloud and then I discovered that it's
just the nonsense because cloud
computing is it's much more than
technical issue it's a lot of
interaction with the provider and a lot
of things between a provider and
customer and a lot of issues regarding
multi-jurisdictional multi-tenant legal
problems so by doing a little project in
my lab on my own cannot really solve
this problem so and then I published a
paper on cloud forensic Center and
overview trying to describe what are the
major dimensions for cloud forensics so
firstly I discussed about the technical
dimension of cloud of cloud forensics
which basically is the mapping the
traditional digital forensic process
into cloud environment this this graphic
is from NIST although the digital
investigation experts haven't really
agreed on what are the standard digital
forensic process but this one is from
respected organization so I just used
that one so basically the digital
forensic process is from collection
examination analysis to reporting and
the preservation of evidence should
cover all the four phases and in each of
the phases there are different different
techniques and procedures associated
with each face
so we should look at how to map all
these faces into the cloud which is very
challenging in a collection phase we
need to consider a proactive collection
of evidence which need to be agreed
between the provider and customer on how
to practically collect data before the
incident and so there are trying side
artifacts their provider side artifacts
for data collection and there are
numerous data sources there are 4
billion mobile endpoints now accessing
the internet and the physical locations
is very hard too hard to be located and
also sampling time synchronization a
cloud in the examination face it
concerns evidence segregation among
different talents who are sharing same
resources and disability how to trace an
event that this happened in cloud and
how to filter numerous data that is
collected from the collection phase into
something useful and patent matching
which is identifying potential criminal
patterns in the in the data that is
collected and in a reduction it's
similar to filtering basically it's
reducing the size of the of the sample
data and then analysis it concerns data
mining reconstruction Avenger
construction which is very cool thing to
think about it's like a crime scene
investigation how to how to reconstruct
the crime scene in a cloud and time
sequence there are still huge problem
with time synchronization over the cloud
and at the same time time sequence is
crucial to forensic analysis because it
determines which incident happened
before and after the sequence of
incidents and finally reporting a
concerns documentation and presentation
to presentation of evidence potentially
to the court and expert testimony in the
preservation and it means chain of
custody which is very complicated in a
cloud admissibility which is under
discussion
learn how to define the miscibility of
the evidence from the cloud soundness of
the evidence transport of the evidence
storage of the data collected and how to
destroy and how to make sure things are
destroyed and the case management of the
forensic case so this is the technical
dimension which is the mass because
there are numerous challenges in this
dimension and and then we kind of
emphasize five main areas of focus on
the technical dimension that we think
are unique and are unique to the cloud
nature and other techniques basically
it's either we need to scale the current
techniques up or we just need to kind of
transform it into the cloud environment
so these five main areas are forensic
data collection in the cloud because of
the data sources are numerous and there
is a the segregation of duty between the
cloud provider and the cloud customer so
it becomes very challenging and then
elastic static and lie forensic tool
kits because cloud is elastic so the
forensic cases can be elastic to and how
to make the tools and procedures elastic
and and how to provide static and lie
forensics tools for large-scale data
centers and so on evidence aggregation
that concerns how to completely
segregate data from different tenants
when it comes to investigation because
you don't when your neighbor is
committing a crime you don't want your
data to be investigated because you are
not related to the crime but how to make
sure that your confidentiality is not
breached when there is investigation on
your neighbor investigative tools in
virtualized environments virtualization
is crucial to cloud computing as it's
very unique from cloud computing as well
so how to mitigate for example
hypervisors because hypervisors will be
a single point of failure to some extent
and it's very much liked by the hackers
proactive preparations which means how
to define the procedures and processes
to
to proactively collect forensic relevant
data before incident happen and how to
collaborate in collecting them between
providing customer and then there is
this organizational dimension of cloth
forensics and in this chart it's
basically describing how these different
parties are interacting in this in this
game and within that organization there
are four different roles investigators
in incident handlers low advisors IT
professionals we assume that every
organization they have their forensic
team but many organization they don't
have this this forensic team and then
they will resort to external assistance
when needed when it comes to techniques
that they cannot provide internally and
then between the clock organizations
there is SLA binding and defining the
roles and responsibilities of each
organization and in this chain of csps
and customers they interact with law
enforcement cell parties and act amia so
the complicated thing here is the
dependencies between provide and
customer because provider might depend
on other provider to provide some
services and then when there's
investigation is very hard to
investigate through this chain and there
is nothing defined yet no policy is no
agreement and to facilitate any kind of
Investigation that is happening in this
kind of situation so basically the areas
of focus here is first segregation of
duties between providers and customer
and also between the law enforcement and
the chain of providers and customer and
also basically it's about defining roles
and responsibilities in this big big
interactive environment and then
collaboration how to facilitate
effective and efficient collaboration
and how to come up with policies both
organizational policy and also from
international level how to how to
provide the policies for these
investigations to to be carried out
effectively and then the legal dimension
of course is very important because now
with the cloud everything will be more
multi jurisdictional than before because
before when you have a network on your
own premise it's only one jurisdiction
but now a multi jurisdiction can be a
default setting for any kind of
Investigation because if people are
moving to the cloud then your data is by
default multi-jurisdictional and
multi-tenancy is about how to invest it
investigate a case when they are sharing
resources among more than one customer
and this is unique to cloud computing as
well quite unique and multi ownership it
comes to who actually owns this piece of
data and then when the data is seized by
law enforcement who is going to react on
this and who is responsible to react
then service level agreement everything
this is the legal binding document for
cloud computing so everything should be
finally defined in SLA on how to address
these questions and then this year I did
a survey towards the digital forensic
experts around the world to ask their
opinions on pro forensic because I was
very confused myself and I can't really
say that I think this is like this so
it's like this so basically we carried a
survey on cloud forensics and critical
criteria for cloud forensic capability
it was launched in February and up to
March after one months we received 156
responses which is amazing for this
community because there are not too many
the digital forensic experts community
is not too big for now and then we have
almost 200 responses up to now so I did
a primarily analysis on the result so
I'm going to share some key findings so
basically
fifty percent of experts believe that
cloud makes forensics harder the main
reasons are loss of data control the
customers are putting data to the cloud
then they don't know what's going on no
access to physical infrastructure you
don't you can't touch the machines you
can't touch the discs etc legal issues
of multi jurisdiction multi-tenancy and
multi ownership lack of tools for
large-scale distributed and virtualized
systems now standard interface for
investigation there's no tool provided
by the providers no provider cooperation
most of providers are not transparent on
investigations and they are not
providing any tools now to investigate
difficulties in producing forensically
sound and admissible evidence in court
this is quite a difficulty in
traditional forensics but it's it's even
more challenging in cloud environment
and then very interestingly forty-two
percent of experts believe that cloud
makes forensics easier the reason why is
that they believe more computing
resources and processing power with
reduced costs will help forensics and
rapidly scalable auditing reporting and
testing analysis can be used for larger
data sets and distributed applications
basically forensics can also take
advantage of the computer power provided
by cloud computing forensic implications
and activities can be centrally
administered and managed centralization
is good for forensics because it
provides certain that standardization as
well investigations can be provided as a
service by the CSP I know some people
who are doing research on forensic as a
service and it's very promising because
in this way more people will be
benefited from standard forensic tools
and procedures I personally believe i'm
personally optimistic i can't say that i
believe it makes it easier but i'm
optimistic so eighty-four percent of the
experts agree that there is a
technical dimension of cloud forensics
eighty-four percent agree there's legal
dimension and 75 believes that there's
organization permission so my
three-dimensional model is validated by
the opinions from the experts so the top
five challenges for cloud forensics
according to the experts our first
jurisdiction ninety percent of experts
believe jurisdiction is a major
challenge and then investigating
external chain of dependences of the
cloud providers as I mentioned before
when the provider is depending on other
providers to provide certain service and
it's almost impossible to carry out
investigation in such a complicated
environment and then like of
international collaboration and alleged
legislative lative mechanism in cross
nation data access and exchange and then
lack of law and the legal advisory then
finally decreased access to and control
over forensic data at all levels from
customer site although most of the
customers are still not aware of their
lack of control over forensic data but
expert believe this is a major challenge
and then the top three opportunities
according to the experts are first of
all establishment of a foundation of
standards and policies which I'm
strongly believe it's a good opportunity
given by the adoption of cloud computing
to the teacher forensic research and
development and then forensics as a
cloud service and certainly cost
effective forensic implementations as
part of cloud infrastructure so we can
see compared to the challenges there or
above seventy percent but the
opportunities are around fifty percent
top three most valuable research
directions according to the experts in
cloud forensics our first design
forensic architecture for the cloud
which I'm working on right now in my
dissertation the question is we need a
new novel architecture or some
architecture that is
evolved from the architecture we have
now and then extending current
investigative tools into the cloud
certainly law so the top five most
needed tools and procedures according to
the experts are procedures and tools to
preserve the soundness of digital
evidence in the cloud and retrieve
forensic data involving confidential
data under jurisdictions and agreements
which services are operating so
basically it's about the you need to
understand where your data is in terms
of the jurisdictions and agreements that
is restricting which is defining how to
retrieve confidential data because in
different jurisdiction is different so
it can be very complicated when your
data is all over the place then
investigative external chain of
dependencies we talked about before and
preserve volatile data in the cloud the
data that is changing every second and
then proactively collect forensics data
so these are the tools that need to be
developed most needed and then service
level agreement so I recently wrote a
paper on key terms that need to be
included in SLA for cloud forensics and
it's going to be published soon
basically covered five six major
sections first we need to discuss what
what is the cloud offering because in
different plant offerings the
investigations are different the
customer has a bigger control in in the
case of infrastructure as a service
because they still have control over
infrastructure both they have access to
logs and stuff and they have less
control and software software as a
service because the providers is taking
responsibility of most of the things and
we need to consider what kind of
operations are putting the cloud and
this is like the basic things we need to
discuss before defining the rest of the
SLA and then there are four different
areas first is access to foreign six
data who has access to the
encryption encryption keys and when
there is investigation how to decrypt
the forensics data and how to access
this case and how to work with these
people who have access to the case and
what are the rights for the
investigators to access these keys and
logs on all levels physical location
access to physical location physical
infrastructure access to disk images and
other forensics data generated by the
provider and the proactively proactive
forensic data collection so this should
be should be considered this kind of
access to foreign 66 I need to be
considered and then technical dimension
mainly is first practice preparation and
forensics data collection transparency
of data collection how data is collected
and the roles and responsibilities
between the providing customer on data
collection and forensic tools what kind
of tools are provided by the provider
and what kind of tools are are needed
from the customer are the responsibility
of the customer to provide and then
evidence segregation how the evidence is
segregated is it agreed between the
providing and customer regarding this
issue virtual environment and hypervisor
investigation what kind of tools are
provided in this count in this area and
the customer and providing need to agree
on on this investigation in virtual
environment and they had deletion how
data is deleted how to make sure data is
deleted and how to prove is deleted
because we know that it's it's hard to
delete even a piece of data on a
computer and how to delete data in a
cloud it can be very challenging and
incident response and recovery what are
the incident response plans and recovery
plans for investigation and security
breach in organizational dimension the
staffing structure between the provide
and customer need to be defined who is
providing what and who is responsible
for what and who is providing the staff
to do investigation and to react to a
law enforcement and then forensics
training who is taking care of trainings
collaboration how to facilitate
collaborations between internally
between the teams in organization and
abrasion externally with other providers
and with law enforcement external
assistance in which cases external
assistance are resulted to and what kind
of services they are providing and what
kind of problems they are helping to
helping the provider or customer to
solve this need to be clearly stated in
SLA and transparency of chain of
dependencies what kind of third party
muscle party what kind of dependent
dependencies is involved in this service
and what are the other providers you are
using in providing these services in
legal dimension main leads discussion on
issues around multi-jurisdictional the
tendency chain of custody who is taking
care of the who is taking care of the
evidence and preserving the evidence
notification when there is law
enforcement coming with a warrant and
using how many how much time the
customer or the provider is notified and
notify so that they can react to it
about resources seizure when law
enforcement want to see is a piece of
resources who is going to react and how
to react forensic sonus how to preserve
the soundness in of the evidence and at
the miscibility change of CSP when there
is a change of the provider how to deal
with this when comes to investigation
and then all these new tube audited so
basically this is about SLA which is not
existing now but we are trying to make
an effort to mmm to define more terms
for forensics and sra for cloud
computing and then this is the project
working on now it's called cloud
forensic capability we are trying to
define a model that is used to assess
the probability of a provider or
customer in their maturity in
Callanetics and we are working with
several providers try to validate this
model and yeah hopefully this will be
something like standard that people can
refer to some of the initiatives i'm
working on collective knowledge i'm
editing a book on cloud forensic it's
going to be published next year early
next year it's called cyber crime and
cloud for analytics application for
investigative processes I have received
some very interesting chapters on the
R&D in this area and i'm going to add it
the volume 2 of this book next year so
it will be out in 2013 and we are
building a cloud forensic network of
experts around the world who are
developing various tools and procedures
in cloud forensics and because i believe
this area is not one person cannot
definitely deal with this so we need a
collective knowledge and build a
community of experts who can share their
research and ideas and work together to
develop tools and solutions for this and
and i'm working on a journal of
california research which is backed up
by the research center in UCD and case
studies to development benchmark project
and stand out SLA and finally i need to
finish my dissertation by the end of the
year so that's very important and so if
anybody is interested in working with me
i'm happy to discuss thank you i can't
this a very fascinating topic and full
alright MELAS oh no you weren't nervous
all is great are there any questions of
kaeun oh there have to be this is a
fascinating area there's one
so no in all your researcher basically
comes down to if you want to do
forensics you have to load your own
stuff too as a person who's going to be
using a cloud service provider you can't
really trust you can't trust the cloud
service providers to do forensics for
you you have to do it yourself no no I I
think the key is in collaboration and
also the key is in the segregation of
duties I personally believe actually the
provider do forensic for you with more
trust trusting more reliable in some
sense because security is security and
forensics in small and medium
enterprises are very weak but if they
are using cloud computing then they can
actually jump to a standard kind of
infrastructure like Google Amazon
Microsoft they will provide a standard
security forensics implementations and
then this small medium companies and
also like smaller companies they can
actually afford this kind of
implementation with very low cost and
that's actually a good thing so I'm
personally optimistic about fitting
although there are many challenges but I
don't believe that we should go back to
the time that we lock everything in the
black box and believe that is secure I
think we should move forward and develop
architecture framework and tools for the
new technology so question up here
one moment let's go ahead you go ahead
and then you um do you see law firms and
accounting firms offering most of these
services no well but I I mean they
should be aware of what other problems
and I believe that more people will
start to work on this and I'm very happy
because at beginning when I was starting
to do this research I basically started
from reading an article from Newsweek
and then I was like two years ago when
cloud company was still emerging and I
was like yeah this is interesting and I
I told my supervisor so i can do claw
for index and inventing a new term is so
cool and then and then I started to my
research and I feel lonely all the time
because at the beginning or not people
like even thinking about call for index
and I was like making them aware of the
potential problems and all these but now
I'm happy that people actually ready
emails to me saying that at least I
found someone is working on this and
this is really important and we've been
we have encountered some cases related
to cloud computing and I think this will
be relevant in the near future so and
more researchers are working on this
area so I'm quite happy and I believe
that more people like lawyers or I mean
people well well start to walk on it it
will take one last question over here
and as he's preparing you know I'm there
are some interesting terms like
computational agriculture you know
that's a that's a cool one too I wish I
was the guy who can call that term so it
seems that it's difficult enough to
think of jurisdiction when it comes to
traditional crime like hacking into
accounts to get credit cards have you
looked into our thought about things
that actually enter into foreign policy
like for example companies that Google
and Facebook and Microsoft almost have
to define their own implicit foreign
policy with respect to like what's
happening in the Middle East or with
respect to attacks that seem to be
originating from China or things like
that yeah I don't talk about China
because I'm from China
yeah that's very relevant salt because
actually I think cyberspace will be
empowering not only businesses education
and research it will be also empowering
politics in some sense because
everything will be digital in the future
and there are their research and
discussion on digital diplomacy digital
foreign policies and all these kind of
things and that's very interesting for
me and actually I was looking at some of
the issues related to social media
social network in all ways with
political movements and all this and
cloud computing will be behind all these
kind of things so some people say there
should be a political dimension of
California 6 or social dimension of
California decks which are very
interesting but I think now it's not a
major concern yet so I think compared to
the three dimensions I defined these are
still kind of marginal in a sense but in
the future maybe we need to include
these two dimensions to divide depending
on how technology is evolving but these
are very interesting i'm really excited
about this q and thank you very much
very much thank you ok we'll get the
next queued up here drawers how are you
ok it's my pleasure to pronounce
introduce your support he's from Harvard
Business School he's going to talk about
what I believe is a very timely subject
interesting as well cloud-based product
development great thanks thanks so I
think my backgrounds a little bit
misleading my bachelor's is a mechanical
engineering and my masters in aerospace
engineering and I worked for several
years at Boeing so with the title of
this is cloud-based product development
with the products being actual physical
products such as airplanes and cars and
things like that so if you're coming for
a pure software development talk he can
still feel free to leave but basically
so so that's my background what I spend
most of my career
are working on was the 787 airplane I
worked on several different sections
most of it was on the wing and the
problem we were trying to solve in
product development in designing an
airplane and the same applies for many
other products is thinking about how the
different disciplines such as
aerodynamics or manufacturing or
structures interact with each other in
the design process so a big piece and
this is what this work is a lot of this
is about is how can you when you link
all these together you create an
extremely big computational problem how
can you solve that and some of the work
in that area so first just to give you a
little bit more background at a note if
everybody's familiar with the aerospace
industry but basically with the Boeing
787 it's been quite a headache if you're
from around here you've probably read
too much about this already but it's
costing companies in aerospace a lot of
money and it's not just Boeing Airbus
has the same issues and a lot of it has
to do with different issues within the
product development process and from a
business perspective this is costing
them a lot of money but it's it's not
just in aerospace industry it's really
in many other industries and
manufacturing in high tech and some
research has been done on this and it
actually looks into looking at what the
long-term effects are of these
development delays in the products and
it's actually five percent drop in long
term market caps so beyond just missing
your deadlines and and the damage from
that it really is irreparable damage to
the companies themselves so this is why
this is a big issue in business and the
root causes and again this is from
research across manufacturing high-tech
companies root causes for this are
technical and engineering problems
needing to redesign the product not
meeting performance back kind of the
typical kinds of things that you would
expect and actually think and this well
proposed here is that the cloud can help
address many of these issues and I'll
explain why and how on top of this
there's actually growing opera
Unity's because this is a growing
problem and the reason it's a growing
problem if you look at globalization
outsourcing it's really making the
entire supply chain within these
companies and it's making the actual
design process much more complex top of
that you have different advances so in
aerospace you have things like composite
materials it adds the many many
variables to the the problem and along
with the integration problems within the
supply chain it makes this an extremely
large and unpredictable process doing
this product development so while this
has been changing the traditional
product development process has actually
been staying the same and it's really
just this the same process been used for
the last 15 years so so what that
actually looks like is you know you just
start with a concept and this comes from
you know some research group that
decides something like the 787 is the
next plane they want to build then those
two detail design phase you have
different analysis disciplines so here
you have things like aerodynamics they
do computational fluid dynamic analysis
which is basically you know you can
that's simulated often done in
high-performance clusters and that feeds
back onto that detailed design so within
the aerodynamic group they come up with
the perfect airfoil shape and they feed
that that back goes through other
analysis disciplines things like
structures that decide you know what is
the actual structure on the inside and
how to get that certified with the FAA
these each keep iterating like this and
this is a very long process you converge
to a final design and then that that's
what gets built so these analysis
disciplines each happen within
engineering silos they can be quite
complex and for example in aerodynamics
there there will be a group of you know
hundreds of engineers that work on
perfecting the perfect shape for an
airplane and they work in a silo and in
perfecting the aerodynamics and the same
thing for many other disciplines and so
this is really where all the time is
spent and this is where we'll try to
improve this through using cloud
computing and also an important thing to
understand is that most of the actual
decisions for the products get made very
early on in the prog development cycle
so really all your constraints
are already defined very early in this
process and that's in the conceptual
phase so how we're going to change this
with cloud-based product development
it's it's similar first stages but when
we get to the analysis disciplines which
are things like on the top you see
something like computational fluid
dynamics which defines the shape and
then analysis discipline something like
finite element analysis to do the
structural analysis these all actually
work off the same airplane obviously and
many of the same variables so there's a
discipline called multidisciplinary
optimization where you can try to tie
these together and and that's a lot of
what the cloud enables is doing this
practically on a real industry problem
so this has been around for a long time
academics have done this before but the
practical reality behind linking all
these simulations if you envision
something like an expensive
computational fluid dynamic run requires
already a high-performance grid to be
able to do that every time you add a
dimension it's really you know adding
another entire dimension to this
computational requirement so when you
link three or four together it becomes
so big it's basically impossible to
solve but what we're doing with a cloud
platform now all of a sudden your
computational capabilities are much
larger than they were before with a grid
and even large companies such as Boeing
and Lockheed Martin they all have large
supercomputers and grids to be able to
solve these type of problems but these
come nowhere close to the computing
power that's necessary to solve if you
really tie everything together in a
practical problem so so what we're doing
is we have these dynamic integrated
databases which is really just storing
all this data and and relating them to
each other so it is a database that
understands where data is coming from
and how they relate to each other then
we have a suite of kind of computation
tools a lot of them have to do with
optimization they're not extremely
complex relatively simple algorithms and
cloud computing resources to solve this
and so these are tied together and then
each of these analysis disciplines
interacts with these databases and these
solvers and through this process there
also
interacting with each other so you're
seeing the you know effect of in
aerodynamics you're changing the shape
of an airfoil how that affects all the
subsequent processes downstream so how
it affects how you design the structure
how it affects how the manufacturing
process happens and different
constraints that are from those
processes that converges to a final
design and goes to production so you
know why hasn't this been adopted well
basically the fundamentals have been
around for a very long time and like I
said academic research has shown that
this is very doable but the problem is
is when you go to a real practical
problem the amount of design variables
in in one in like a wing for the
variables that are used to do
certification by the FAA are very large
so you can think of millions of
different designing variables and on top
of that on every design variable or
every local area that you have to
provide analysis for you have many many
different constraints so this problem
becomes extremely large and academic
work is shown as possible but it wasn't
really until with the 787 and this is
actually on a derivative version of the
787 that we for the first time solved
something really practical problem in
the industry that was actually applied
on on the derivative airplane and I'll
share some of those results a little bit
later but really not until after that we
use this used clusters to do this so
high performance clusters no cloud and
now that cloud computing has become
available this really disrupts the
entire cost structure to do these type
of problems but also let's Boeing do
problems that previously weren't
possible before so many people would
argue that you know high-performance
computing why why are using the cloud to
do this but the reality is is that very
large problems even you know you could
say theoretically you have access to
very large grids but practical realities
are with cloud computing this becomes
extremely accessible and before they're
not even within companies so this is a
little bit of a tangent but to bring
everybody to the same level so why do
you virtualize high performance
computing so I've mentioned a couple of
reasons but most people only talk about
the problems
and most people that do high performance
computing they really prefer not to do
it on the cloud or virtualized and and
the reason is that there's obviously the
security issues which in aerospace and
defense get even bigger than the typical
issues performance scalability so there
are performance issues in certain cases
and different integration problems but
as I'll show is you know if you can
overcome these and I think each of these
is very easy to address and and think
about as a company and how to address
those through different methods but the
benefits are much larger than some of
the risks you're taking especially if
you compare it to doing it on a cluster
so the new opportunities that they
really provide is again this
accessibility and I think people
underestimate this and perhaps in
academia it's relatively easy to get
access to two large clusters or recreate
your problems so it so it becomes
practical and whatever resources you do
have in industry you know these really
large problems just don't get solved
because very easily people say well it's
not possible so what cloud computing
does is it really provides this to the
engineers within the companies and it
does actually provide a couple of new
capabilities too and so one is a
checkpoint restart which is I guess
people have mentioned before but it
basically makes it easier to kind of
backup your data and have reliability
and you can actually have a higher
reliability with the cloud then then
with a grid and the dynamic workload
migration which is very interesting once
you get a problem to a certain size you
can actually expand the number of CPUs
you're using dynamically as you're
solving this problem so this is really
interesting where you don't you know you
don't even set what number of nodes
you're going to start using but it
basically dynamically scale so whatever
you need and some of this work is by
josh from vmware but there's been some
research done on looking at specific
type of problems and looking at the
scalability and the performance of that
and actually some of these bars and in
that small graph you'll see there but
i'm not an expert in this but those bars
are five or six different
a couple of them include cloud computing
and virtualized machines and really the
performance is almost the same obviously
there are situations where it's not but
if you focus your problem in the right
way and understand where the
difficulties are you can overcome many
of these so how does it specifically for
computer-aided engineering change what
we're actually doing well in basic
applications it just gives you this
computing power unless engineers be able
to kick off you know a hundred runs of
different air/fuel shapes at the same
time it would take you to solve one so
that's that's a really big really big
benefit and yes it's going to be done on
a grid but you know the reality is is
Boeing's not going to invest in in
clusters that are so large that you
really have an unlimited scalability and
in the type problems you're solving you
can also do more complex implementations
so basically with multi disc for
optimization like I mentioned before
some of those are just not possible with
the scale of grid computing so with
cloud those are possible and I think
there's new possibilities of even more
advanced type of computations that
people haven't even thought of to do
just because the computer computational
requirements are so big so this is a
little bit more about the work
specifically on the 787 wing and a lot
of this comes from my thesis in
multidisciplinary optimization at the
University of Washington but basically
you know it's the same process you start
with the the concept detail design for
the analysis disciplines this is where
we you know basically hack together a
bunch of the different processes and the
computational tools to do simulation for
different structural analysis
aerodynamics and manufacturing
constraints things like that link those
together come up with a final design and
go to production and so some of this
work was also done at Boeing and
eventually applied on the on the
derivative airplane and the results were
pretty astounding so we're doing this on
a design that's actually already been
you know basically finalized by Boeing
as the best possible design and we were
able to save hundreds of millions of
dollars in performance improvement and
how we're able to do this is
slight increases in performance and it
for example and wait for Boeing save you
know thousands of dollars per plane so
when you're selling a thousand planes
this quickly adds up but these you know
these designs are difficult to optimize
but we really saw a lot of benefits from
integrating the processes and being able
to capture those interdependencies more
importantly we're actually able to
reduce a lot of development time so this
is exactly where you know we think the
market can really take advantage of this
is being able to reduce the time to do
the product development now I'm not
going to say that all the issues for
example of 787 are coming from
simulation type of tools and things like
that but if you're able to do you know
the core product development process is
much much faster it obviously reduces
your risk of a delay so not a little bit
more about the architecture that we're
developing and a lot of what we have
developed to do this so within the
architecture we basically have four four
main pieces one is data this is
basically just cloud databases but a big
difference is they're dynamic real-time
engineers and different organizations
can all link to the same databases and
look at what's what's going on real time
make sure you have real-time data and
and it captures also the different
relationships between the different
models so something like computational
fluid dynamics is very different than
finite element analysis but between the
two there's many things are in common
for example geometry analysis and this
is where we link into third party tools
so we link into the all the leading kind
of software providers to do this
analysis and and we work together with
them to be able to provide you know the
leading analysis capabilities then the
process side partner with different
organizations also things like MATLAB
and other tools are available and and we
use relatively simple algorithm so these
are extremely scalable in optimization
often you're just doing derivatives and
compounding those together that it's
relatively simple math but it's at
extremely large scale and lastly it's
the computing piece and this is
basically where we
you know move this to the cloud most of
our work has been done with amazon web
services but there's there's many you
know different vendors are available to
do this and it's we're basically just
trying to provide the architecture to be
able to put this on the cloud so as
somebody mentioned before I think was
Mike Franklin about the importance of
people on the side so we also have many
interfaces for people to interact with
these processes that are that are
happening one is a metrics dashboards
it's more for kind of management to see
you know what's going on we have an
engineering portal that lets you
interface and see real-time what's
happening as you're running this entire
process then an API interface so that
lets you really just integrate anything
you want so especially in the fence
there might be certain type of
proprietary codes that you don't you
know want to share or you can integrate
those yourself and program in what you
want and then there's an IT dashboard to
keep track of the IT side for for the
organization so what benefits is really
get you in the end so for management the
biggest thing is cost reductions but
especially increase visibility control
being able to do things faster and most
of the cost reduction is actually not as
much from the just the standard kind of
grid to cloud cost savings but a lot of
it is about more efficient use of your
most expensive resources which are often
the people and then engineers benefit
the most so from from doing this type of
work on the cloud it's actually much
easier to collaborate across you know
across the world so with the 787 program
many of the pieces or most of the pieces
are not actually even produced in in the
United States so with the wing it's
built in Japan so interfacing with a
Japanese engineer and and some other
suppliers becomes much easy easier when
everybody's using the same system and
can understand you know why design
choices are made certain way so finally
a little bit about I guess this is about
cloud future so what I see is a future
and then this is just my opinion but I
think a lot of people right now are
working on
partially moving existing applications
to the cloud and then doing you know
just extremely big data so data that's
been around and doing simple processes
on that data but where I see the future
really going is is and we're trying to
create that a bit with this
infrastructure is being able to solve
new types of problems being able to
improve you know products not just do
things faster but do things smarter and
as was mentioned before too by Jim about
you know being data-driven research so
so the results you get out of one of
these extremely large multi-discipline
altima zation it's just a new wing
design but understanding you know how
all the things interact with each other
and why this new design is better than
the previous design that's really the
biggest benefit that you get out of this
and especially in research it's a hugely
beneficial and eventually it's all about
moving towards being able to not just
scale everything and make everything
highly paralyzed abut being able to do
this I've extremely complex algorithms
and computationally very intense
processes I think that's where the
future is going and that's where where
we're trying to go so thanks for
listening I'd love to hear any questions
if you want thank you yours you know
this is great this is really good this
explains why I've been able to get on a
787 yet and it also gives me hope for
the 797 I mean it's going to really be
optimized and the you know the process
will are there any questions I just
wanted a comment I think it's a
fantastic talk and it illustrates a
couple of things that are obvious but
people often neglect one is it Dave
Patterson years ago pointed out that the
cool thing about cloud service is that a
thousand processors for one day cost the
same as one processor for a thousand
days right and you know that's that's
really the point that you made
implicitly and it's it's a huge point
the other thing is that you can achieve
parallelism through things like
parameter sweeps as opposed to try to
paralyze the algorithms right so both of
those things seem really important it's
just a great case study everything any
other questions the right over here
yes I am wondering if Boeing is engaged
with Amazon in a private cloud
arrangement is is that how you solve
your security problems not using a
public cloud yeah so just to be clear
first of all I don't work for Boeing
anymore I just graduated last week
congratulations so the cloud work we're
doing now this is work research I did on
the side while attending Harvard we'd
like to get bowing to use it a lot of
the work in the case study that was all
done on grids but we've basically shown
that we can get that capability to the
cloud so actually you know right now I'm
starting a start-up to be able to do
this but right now Boeing doesn't do any
kind of cloud computation yet and I
think you know it's going to take a
little time and probably there's other
people that will probably move first but
at the end of the day if you look at you
know things like Salesforce people are
comfortable with their most sensitive
data within companies on the cloud so I
think eventually aerospace and other
industries will move there to thank you
other questions okay yours thank you
very much it was a very fascinating case
study I appreciate it let's give him a
hand please uh